in this important segment we will
develop a method for finding the PDF of
a general function of a continuous
random variable a function G of X which
in general could be nonlinear the method
is very general and involves two steps
the first step is to find the CDF of Y
and then the second step is to take the
derivative of the CDF and then find the
PDF most of the work lies here in
finding the CDF of Y and how do we do
that well since Y is a function of the
random variable X we replace Y by G of X
and now we're dealing with a probability
problem that involves a random variable
X with a known PDF and we somehow
calculate this probability so let us
illustrate this procedure through some
examples in our first example we let X
be a random variable which is uniform on
the range from 0 to 2 and so the height
of the PDF is 1/2 and we wish to find
the PDF of the random variable Y which
is defined as X cube so since X goes all
the way up to 2 Y goes all the way up to
8 the first step is to find the CDF of Y
and since why is a specific function of
X we replace that functional form and we
write it this way so we want to
calculate the probability that X cube is
less than or equal to a certain number Y
let us take cubic roots of both sides of
this inequality this is the same as the
probability that X is less than or equal
to Y to the one-third now we only care
about values of Y that are between 0 and
8 so this calculation is going to be for
those values of y for other values of y
we know that the PDF is equal to 0 and
there's no work that needs to be done
there okay now Y is less than or equal
to 8 so the cubic root of y is less than
or equal to 2 so Y to the one-third is
going to be a number somewhere in this
range let's say this number we want the
probability that X is less than or equal
to that value so that probability is
equal to this area under the PDF of X
and since it is uniform this area is
easy to find it's the height which is
1/2 times the base which is y to the 1/3
so we continue this calculation and we
get 1/2 times y to the 1/3 so this is
the formula for the CDF of Y for values
of little Y between 0 & 8 this completes
step 1 the second step is simple
calculus we just need to take the
derivative of the CDF and the derivative
is 1/2 times 1/3 this exponent Y to the
power of
- two thirds or in a cleaner form 1/6
times one over Y to the power two-thirds
so the form of this PDF is not a
constant anymore Y is not a uniform
random variable the PDF becomes larger
and larger as Y approaches zero and in
fact in this example it even blows up
when Y becomes closer and closer to zero
so this is the shape of the PDF of Y our
second example is as follows you go to
the gym you jump on the treadmill and
you set the speed on the treadmill to
some random value which we call X and
that random value is somewhere between 5
and 10 km/h and the way that you set it
is chosen at random and uniformly over
this interval so X is uniformly
distributed on the interval between 5
and 10 you want to run a total of 10
kilometers how long is it going to take
you let the time it takes you be denoted
by Y and the time it's going to take you
is the distance you want to travel which
is 10 divided by the speed with which
you will be going so the random variable
Y is defined in terms of X through this
particular expression we want to find
the PDF of Y first let us look at the
range of the random variable Y since X
takes values between 5 and 10 Y takes
values between 1 & 2
therefore the PDF of Y is going to be
zero outside that range and let us now
focus on values of Y that belong to this
interesting range so one less than y
less than or equal to two and now we
start with our two-step program we want
to find the CDF of Y namely the
probability that capital y takes a value
less than or equal to a certain little Y
in this range we recall the definition
of capital y so now we're dealing with a
probability problem that involves the
random variable capital X whose
distribution is given to us now we
rewrite this event as follows we move X
to the other side this is the
probability that X is larger than or
equal after we move the little Y also to
the left hand side X being larger than
or equal to 10 over little Y now Y is
between 1 & 2 10 over Y is going to be a
number between 5 and 10 so 10 over y is
going to be somewhere in this range
we're interested in the probability that
X is larger than or equal to that number
and this probability is going to be the
area of this rectangle here and the area
of that rectangle is equal to the height
of the rectangle now the height of this
rectangle is going to be 1/5 this is the
choice that makes the total area under
this curve be equal to 1 times the base
and the length of the base is this
number 10 minus that number it's 10
minus 10 over Y so this is the form of
the CDF of Y for Y's in this range to
find the PDF of y
we just take the derivative and we get
1/5 times the derivative of this term
which is minus 10 divided by y squared
but when we take the derivative of 1
over Y that gives us another minus sign
the two minus signs cancel and we obtain
2 over y squared and if you wish to plot
this it starts at 2 and then as Y
increases the PDF actually decreases and
this is the form of the PDF of the
random variable Y this is the form which
is true when Y lies between 1 & 2 and of
course the PDF is going to be 0 for
other choices of little Y so what we
have seen here is a pretty systematic
approach towards finding the PDF of the
random variable Y again the first step
is to look at the CDF right the CDF in
terms of the random variable X whose
distribution is known and then solve a
probability problem that involves this
particular random variable and then in
the last step you just need to
differentiate the CDF in order to obtain
the PDF